so guys we have a lot of new footage
regarding the mandolin season threes
without further Ado let's get straight
into it so the trailer starts off with a
new shot of Mando's we have a dialogue
line saying there's something dangerous
happening out there as we cut to a new
shot of some mandalorians flying through
the sky using the jet pack with fire
explosions going in the background and I
gotta say this is the money shot of the
trailer because what an awesome shot
this is and it's getting me really
excited for the action scenes for this
season and in the next shot we have some
footage of aliens and some familiar
looking ones as well now this is a
complaint that a lot of people had with
the new Star Wars TV shows and movies
that there wasn't a lot of alien
representation so to have more of them
in demand Lauren is a really good sign
and I'm excited to see this then we have
an awesome shot of Mando holding baby
Yoda or grogu as he is walking away
shooting at something now baby Yoda
isn't in his floating pod so maybe that
got destroyed or they don't have access
to it at this moment then have a new
dialogue line that I'll play for you
guys now safe travels hang on kid and in
this scene in the background we can see
some drivers here and also protocol
Droid that looks very very familiar to
C3PO I don't believe it is C3 Pro just a
random protocol Droid but still a pretty
cool sight we then have some footage of
grogu relaxing on a chair here using a
fork to bring some treats to him because
this man is lazy and this footage
actually comes from a clip that they've
released from the show it's not really
new but I thought I'd quickly break it
down for you guys anyway that is about
everything for this video so if you did
enjoy please leave a like and consider
subscribing and let me know what you are
most excited to see in the Mandalore in
season 3 in the comment section Below
have a great day guys